questions surround the death of a
newborn baby who died in foster care
now the i-team has uncovered a document
which reveals the foster parents were
previously investigated for neglect
in an unrelated case more than two years
ago now in this exclusive interview the
child's grandmother is looking for
answers
as vanessa murphy reports this isn't the
first tragedy for the family this year
this is eci joelle the only thing
that you want is justice this is eci's
grandmother
she's asked the eye team to protect her
identity
last april her daughter was stabbed to
death in a parking lot right in front of
her
metro police say the killer is her
ex-boyfriend she was a new mom to baby
isaiah
the grandmother says child protective
services or cps took custody of the
infant
the same day she says she expected they
would soon be reunited
and in the meantime she prepared to
permanently care for him
i need my grandson back because
i'm going to be ready okay
to help him she says she repeatedly
reached out to a cps caseworker to
ask to be reunited with her grandson i
am ready
to get him and ready
and i was very happy okay
he never returned my messages
she tells the i-team she finally
received a call from the clark county
coroner's office
he said no i have bad news for you
and he told me that he's dead i screamed
i screamed i was very mad
she says no details about the child's
death were shared with her
the i-team dug for answers and found
that according to the coroner's office
at two months and 14 days old isi died
at university medical center
after an incident in the master bedroom
of a foster family assigned to care for
him
that's 26 days after the grandmother
says cps took custody of him
eci's cause of death is pending we also
obtained this child fatality disclosure
which states the department of family
services received a report
that the child had been found
unresponsive in his crib
by his foster parent it also states that
the same foster parents
were previously investigated a report
was received alleging neglect
in 2018 for at least one other child in
their care
the allegations in that case were found
unsubstantiated
our clients need to know what happened
attorney andre lago marcino is
representing the family
although a lawsuit has not been filed
they need to proceed
with all the natural processes of
grieving and
getting answers the i-team reached out
to cps for answers
in an email a spokesman wrote that cps
is awaiting the coroner's report
the foster parents have not been charged
their license is on hold and under
investigation
and they currently do not have any
foster children
when we asked why cps isn't sharing
information with a grandmother
we were told that confidentiality
requirements preclude cps from sharing
information with her
without parental consent again the
child's father is charged with murder
records show he's currently going to be
transferred to a mental health facility
and the child's mother was killed as she
grieves the loss of her daughter
the grandmother is in disbelief about
the loss of her grandson
in my heart i think she's not dead
it's not easy it's very hard i love him
vanessa murphy 8 news now
you heard vanessa talk there about
excuse me parental consent
apparently she followed up with three
additional emails asking cps about the
confidentiality regarding the child
since the mother is dead and according
to records the father has been declared
not competent for trial
however no additional response or
explanation was given